[Music]
i've always been interested in
[Music]
what's out there and you know
understanding the universe
and how it works how it formed
today one of the newest things that
astronomers have found
in in the universe are these exoplanets
so planets that are
beyond our solar system it is
fascinating to think that the solar
system
we are in is may not be unique that
there are many
of them and that they are very different
there have been more than 4 000
exoplanets discovered and
with the improvements in technology
there are many more that have been
discovered every day
the planets that have been found are
very different
the planets are bigger or smaller and
they may have a very different
composition
and so it is very important to try to
grasp their properties a little bit
better
ultimately to see if any of those
planets could be habitable
the high pressure physics is the study
of the properties of materials under
high pressure meaning pressure exceeding
those that are fine on the surface of
the earth
i try to understand how materials behave
at the pressures and temperature
conditions existing
within planets and so what i mostly
study
are minerals and iron compounds
and water and water rises that are
believed to be the main constituents of
planetary bodies in my research i use
giant lasers
to compress and simultaneously heat
materials
to high pressures and high temperatures
and then we use additional lasers to
generate
bright x-ray sources that are used to
take a snapshot
of the materials we can tell
if the material is still solid if it is
liquid
and if it has undergone phase
transitions which means if it had
changed if the add-ons arrangement has
changed
a super earth is a planet that is
bigger than the earth and that is
expected to have a
terrestrial composition what we have
found is that
at the pressures and temperatures
expected in
large extrasolar planets the properties
of these materials are very different
from what they are within the earth they
undergo phase transitions that do not
happen within the earth
that has a dramatic effect on
the planetary interior structure and on
the planet
properties
what it tells us is that the fact that
we see a super earth
behind our solar system and that
super earth is in the hobby double zone
which is defined as the distance from
the
from the star that allows for water to
be liquid
it doesn't necessarily mean that that
planet is habitable
just because you know if it is too big
or too small
that interior structure may be
completely different
so that generate a planet that is very
different
from the earth
[Music]